what is up man look I ain't trying to
get into no politics but it feels like
there's just a lot of drama in terms
between the rappers out there whether
it's yourself and other guys and you
know it just seems like there's a lot of
um
like not a lot of people moving together
out there yeah definitely not is that
like uh it's all politic driven
yeah definitely it's it's a bunch of
Street [__]
that that that you know hinders music
for sure I feel like La that kind of got
in the way of La kind of moving because
you know there was a moment when La was
kind of like cold you know what I mean
yeah I feel like because a lot of the up
and coming artists out of LA
the politics I guess get in the way of
the music now Stockton's a way different
city some very small place yeah so it's
definitely not the same dynamic because
I'm sure
when [__] happens in Stockton it's very
small I've been there you know small
everybody went to school together yeah
related it's a lot different right yeah
but for you like do you think that
there's any
like progress in the right direction or
is it still kind of like everyone's just
kind of divided doing their own thing
[Music]
um
I mean as of right now people like that
[__] though like like I feel that's
what's driving it like people like
seeing that that beef and [__] and yeah
and that drama and [__]
yeah it's crazy because I kind of feel
like Stockton's kind of like the West
Coast like Jacksonville kind of like
Jacksonville's like rap scene is like
kind of driven by like the [__] beef
[__] and I feel like yeah the Stockton
shit's kind of similar like it's just so
much beef and I feel like it helps it's
not good for the human beings involved
not that it helps with it helps with the
with the getting the streams up and
numbers up for sure especially like
YouTube and stuff
it's like a give and a take though
because it's like if you lean into that
[__] there's like real life
ramifications yeah yeah for sure you
gotta know what you signed up for yeah
but yeah
that's that's that's what people like
right now do you feel like you be
leaning into that [__] a little bit just
to kind of help the music or
I mean I always been the type like
whatever whatever be happening I just
leave it out the music because I I I
treat it like two separate entities you
feel me like this is really my job
through like like business you feel me
like I don't wanna
it ain't I I just I try to just do [__]
like look at you professionally you feel
me yeah but and as far as that I'm just
[__] all that [__] yeah for sure yeah I
mean there's been a lot of guys losing
their life out there too man like you
know like the like the slowby dude
obviously rest in peace but a lot of a
lot of dudes there
I feel like I've heard a few people
losing their life out there they're like
I just follow the fizzler bro that's
this will just be keeping me yeah it's
not with the Stockton [__] yeah for sure
um for you because you're kind of like
one of the Pioneers out there I would
say that you're probably in terms of
like catalog and like you know being
able to tour and do certain [__]
you're probably the most successful guy
out of Stockton do you feel any pressure
or any responsibility kind of being like
the national face of a city like that uh
yeah a little bit bad save time it's
just
I really just be so like worried about
myself like I don't really care what
what how what people expect or you feel
me think of me it's just I'm just so
focused and dialed in on
on myself and try to like better myself
so other people look at that like as a
as a you know a good representation it's
just it is what it is you feel me
naturally
when do you feel like you kind of like
figured out how to like properly
turn the rap [__] into a business and
like really monetize your fan base
uh I started I started looking in the
analytics everything like where where
certain fans to listen to music from uh
like top cities like what type of like
I'm really looking at what type of songs
they're streaming the most you feel me
like
like certain rap songs that do good on
YouTube but then like like a song that's
for the females like singing melodizing
that's that's doing it'll get on like
like Spotify or something and I'm
looking at and it's like cities that I
never expected so like where
like right now my Spotify list last time
I looked at it I think
top five I think it was like Melbourne
Australia London
uh it was like three out of country
cities oh [__] yeah and it'd be like
it'd be like for songs like like the the
the the singing songs you feel me that's
so crazy to think like Australia's
really far Halo foreign
so when you see some [__] like that or
you're like damn maybe we should try to
go do some shows out there or
run some ads out there try to you know
like like how do you take that
information and like how do you apply it
to like what you're doing
uh yeah we try to we try to do like try
to try to have ads reach towards towards
that way
um
we we were actually speaking to somebody
from out there like a promoter trying to
get some shows together
but uh that's on hold right now trying
to put that together uh try to have a
show in Canada and then and they didn't
even let me in which was weird because
they let me in in uh Toronto and uh
Montreal is it because of your record
yeah but but it did me so greasy this
time like they looked up everything like
they even uh broken even getting they
was bringing up stuff from like when he
was 14. really this is crazy was this
Vancouver yeah Vancouver damn so like
you how does it work you get to the
border so yeah we get over there we go
through the little uh I forgot what it's
called uh what's it called when you go
we go to TJ Customs Customs yeah so we
win customs
um
they see me whatever I guess I guess I
kind of throw them off with the face
tattoos and [__] uh they they looked me
up I guess they seen I was a rapper then
they look up everything else that's on
the internet the indict the the little
indictment [__] just the [__] that was
on like blogs and all that [__] so all
that pop up
day on everything I on my on my two
suitcases I got two bandanas on it just
to identify it right and so you know it
when you yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying but but they happen to be blue so
they asking why is why is it blue I'm
like that's the that's the first thing I
see I just put it on there yeah but
they have they bring me to like a little
room in the back
they're like we gotta ask you a couple
questions
I'm like all right whatever [__] it
bro they have me in there for like eight
hours eight hours bro just add like like
damn you're interrogating me just to
deny you from I hope my whole luck like
asking me about my whole life like
everything like
go back to the waiting room
all right there's a couple more
questions we gotta ask go back in here
for like two hours I go back to the
waiting room
they had me doing that back and forth
and then and then the day was coming to
an end there was nobody else coming in
there was like
um
uh based on the information you gave us
we still got to do some more research
like more stuff come up
so I'm like damn they're like uh it
might be a it might be a a a legal issue
now
because you're they're trying to sell as
an active [__] and you feel me just a
little [__] like that now now it's a
legal issue and I'm like a legal issue
like like what are you talking about I
instantly called I actually called Matt
who's a lawyer and yeah the lawyer and
my real lawyer right uh mark
so I call them they get in contact with
them trying to see what's up uh uh Mark
and Matt get a hold of it uh the uh was
it the embassy or something like that
trying to talk to them uh they're like
you're gonna have to spend the night and
uh in custody so we could do more
homework on you what the [__] yeah just
to try to get into a country yeah I was
like [__] that I gotta go they're like
you can't leave there's no there's
unless you can find a flood there's like
we'll give you an exception if you could
find a flight to the US right now we'll
let you leave but they were like there
isn't any though so you're gonna have to
spend the night and it could possibly
become a legal issue because you're
organized uh would they say a gang
member that's coming into the country or
some [__] like that
so I'm looking I'm like give me five
minutes bro I find a flight right now so
we looking there I'm on the three-way
with Matt and a lawyer and we're just
trying to find a flight to get up out of
there the first flight I seen was in New
York so I just bought a ticket to New
York got up out of there what the [__]
bro yeah just to get it so you were
trying to drive like you drove to the
Border or did you fly there we flew so
you fly into Vancouver to the airport
and before they let you into the country
they pretty much hit you with the line
of course yeah so
so when I first went to uh Toronto the
dude kind of gave me a little bit of
issue I got in contact with my lawyer
Thunder but uh but the dude was cool so
what they were saying they really depend
on who's working at the time right but I
guess Vancouver more uh strict because
uh it's connected to California you feel
right damn that's crazy so you just flew
to New York yeah flew to New York spent
the night over there and had to fly back
that [__] is well I was on a plane for
like a whole day but that sounds like a
terrible 24 it's terrible 32 hours
terrible